فور وصولنا الى هنا وخصوصا بالامس اذا ما
سالت اي احد موجود بالشارع او اي مكان كان
الكل يتوقع اليوم ان يكونوا بالملاجئ الكل
كان يتوقع ان تدوي صفارات الانذار مع يعني
حلول سنويه هذا الحرب لانه باعتقادهم بان
الرئيس الروسي كان سيوجه رسائل كبيره بهذا
اليوم وكان هناك ايضا تخوف كما كنا قد
ذكرنا بكل الرسائل السابقه من فتح الجبهه
الشماليه طبعا اليوم هي الثانويه العاصمه
هادئه الحركه طبيعيه مئه بالمئه الكل
المحال يعني فتحت ابواب منذ الصباح اتحدث
عن المحل التي اصلا تفتح لان هناك بعض
المحل ما زالت مقفله منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
والناس يعني هم بحاله ترقب يعني هذا
الارتياح يسمونه
الترقب مع قلق لانهم كل ما تسال احد يقول
لك لا نستطيع ان نتوقع ماذا يمكن ان يفعل
الرئيس الروسي او ماذا يمكن ان يفاجئنا
وباي لحظه ومن هنا يعني كان هذه الاجواء
ايضا موجوده لدى المسؤولين يعني بكل
الاجازات التي سمعناها مع المسؤولين الروس
هنا هناك تخوف من اي عمليه باي لحظه من اي
صاروخ ممكن ان يسقط باي لحظه ولكن طبعا
كما قلت لك الاجواء هادئه تماما لا شيء
هنا العاصمه بحالتها الطبيعيه عندما نختم
هذا المباشر ساريك يعني كيف هو الوضع هنا
بان هناك مصالح غربيه بهذه الحرب بان ليست
هي فقط قضيه شعب وقضيه
اسس وقضيه مبادئ ولكن بالرغم من كل ذلك
يقولون بان ايقاف الروس هو امر ضروري
وبالتالي نحن لا نملك اي شيء سوى
حتى بعد سنه حتى
في الحديث ايضا مع رسوله في المؤتمر
الصحفي